Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full willow episode 1 and episode 2 video it's
like the big Disney Plus Series right now that
lucasfilm is putting out if you're not familiar
with the series it is a sequel to the events of
the movie which is sort of George Lucas's version
of a Star Wars story but done in a Pure Fantasy
Universe if you're a long time Star Wars fan
there are a lot of familiar Concepts inside Willow
like the lifeblood of the universe a force that
flows through all living things like that sounds
very familiar if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos and
careful for spoilers from the first two episodes
if you haven't seen them yet I'll just start at
the beginning work our way through shot by shot
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments as we go
along like I said the series is meant to be more
of a Pure Fantasy take on a lot of the familiar
Star Wars types of tropes like the force itself
is their version of magic basically Elora Danan
is the child of Prophecy like their version of an
Anakin Skywalker and there's a lot of twists
with this whole prophecy which the series is
covering look the series is actually based on the
Fulfillment of the prophecy that they talk about
in the movie like the prophecy is finally coming
true and just like in the Star Wars Universe I
think one of the big twists is it'll be a very
Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader kind of twist with
the fulfillment of the actual prophecy like
they're hyping up this giant dark villain
called the withered crone but I think that's kind
of a misdirect the way that sorsha's mother was
kind of a misdirect in the first movie like a mid
bad like the withered Crone is a mid-bat but the
ultimate danger is an Elora Danan pulling a full
Darth Vader the prophecy that they talk about says
that she's going to become Empress of the entire
world like unite the entire world and become the
most powerful Sorceress in the world doesn't that
sound a lot like Anakin Skywalker's prophecy the
prophecy of the force he'll bring balance but will
it be to one side or the other like what will he
be balancing because in the episode you hear a
couple different versions of the prophecy one from
sorsha's side like it sounds like a more positive
spin on the prophecy but later in the gate they
find that everyone's been killed and written in
human blood on the walls is a darker version of
Prophecy but I think that darker prophecy also
refers to Laura Dannon because it also talks
about this person uniting the entire world it just
depends on which side of this you fall like on the
darker side or the Light Side who's she going to
unite the world for they also do a similar thing
in the Game of Thrones Universe they've also
done it on House of the Dragon tooth the whole
Prophecy of the prince who was promised the long
night who is going to be the Fulfillment of that
Prophecy in the Game of Thrones Universe there's
a lot of characters throughout the timeline that
misinterpret the prophecy I think that's the
same Vibe they're going with in this series
like everybody thinks that they know what the
prophecy means Willow keeps having this vision
of the future where he sees everyone has died
in this giant Battlefield this big final battle
he keeps thinking that a Elora Danan has to die in
order to fulfill the prophecy that's also probably
a misdirect too he's probably misinterpreting his
Visions the actual opening scene is basically a
recap of the events of the movie because it's
been almost 35 years since the movie came out
there's a lot of people that are watching this
that either haven't seen the movie or haven't seen
it in a long time I'm not sure who the adventurers
Workshop were supposed to be in the book is also
a bit of a Lord of the Rings kind of reference
it's like it's the beginning of Lord of the Rings
or the end of The Lord of the Rings where you
see Frodo and Bilbo both writing the story of
their adventures and calling it The Lord of the
Rings this book is called Willow because it's
about the willow character in their Adventures the
symbol on the cover is the symbol that Marx Elora
Danan is the child of Prophecy sorsha narrates
the recap of the events of the movie and she
claims she eventually did marry madmartigan they
had two children together they're supposed to
be twins if it wasn't clear kid is the name of
their daughter and she's more of an Arya Stark
type she's meant to be a combination of the two of
them like part Warrior Princess and part scoundrel
with a heart of gold she doesn't really care
about courtly life she doesn't care about being
a princess she doesn't want to marry the prince
of the neighboring Kingdom greydon haster who's
played by Tony revolori, flash Thompson himself
from the Spider-Man movies the person that she's
fighting in the Doctor Doom looking mask is Jade
Claymore played by Erin kellyman who's her love
interest she explained that her parents died when
she was a baby I don't know if they're going to
reveal that she had famous parents as well too or
if she's just meant to be a commoner they spend
most of the first episode explaining a lot of the
lore behind the series or re-explaining things or
explaining some of the new ideas like the whole
magical barrier that exists around Their Kingdoms
madmartigan and sorshia's son is named Airk for
madmartigan's friend from the movie he seems like
more of a man like madmartigan was papa bless.
The girl he calls Dove obviously big reveal she
is secretly a Elora Danan and they've just hidden
her identity from her and physically hidden her
birthmark using magic because all these younger
characters are supposed to be in their early to
mid 20s I'm guessing only about 20 years have
passed since the events of the movie even though
in real life it's been almost 35 years since the
movie came out and they've just made her think
this whole time that she's just a common scullery
made inside the castle so that they can keep an
eye on her if he didn't catch it either she's
also naturally a redhead that'll probably be a
bigger thing later on because she's blonde on the
series right now they said that they've just been
dying it blonde to help hide her identity they
revealed the barrier is a magical force field
that was created by Fin raziel and cherylindra
from the first movie the fairy queen for the
express purpose of protecting Elora but in reality
everyone has been enjoying this protection this
whole time so it's been relatively peaceful
inside Their Kingdoms since the events of the
first movie but this is just meant to be a small
part of the world there are other continents
other really dangerous groups that live outside
the barrier like the bone reavers I think their
group is meant to be a reference to Kail's bone
armor from the first movie there are a lot of
actors that are reprising their roles from the
events of the first film if you watch the movie
you probably recognized a lot of people there are
a lot of actors that did come back to play their
characters again they keep referencing madmartigan
many times during the first couple of episodes and
the whole idea is that a long time ago sorsha sent
him on a quest to find a powerful magical artifact
called the kymerian cuirass which is from the
same race that a Laura Dannon comes from Willow
says that she's the last of the chimerians like
the last of their bloodline so they're meant to
be like Willow's version of the valyrians from
The Game of Thrones Universe like this ancient
very powerful race that has died out and as far
as we know there's only one member of their race
that's left so this kymerian cuirass sort of like
their version of a valerian and steel breastplate
super strong super powerful Ron Howard and the
showrunner said that mattigan is still meant to
be alive he could always show up at some point
during the series it would be weird if he didn't
Cameo during season one like Val Kilmer still very
much alive so I am expecting him to show up at
some point in this quest for this special curus
they explained the bourbon character used to be
his Squire and was on the journey with him and he
actually did find it within their group he's meant
to be like the madmartigan type of character like
the scoundrel with the Heart of Gold like he's
in the dungeon not because he's evil but because
he got bored and he did something to get himself
in trouble there's this whole subplot about Kit
having to marry Tony revelori's character great
and Haster because they're uniting the kingdoms
and they're waiting for Elora Danan to fulfill
the prophecy and become the leader of the entire
world so I think it's a bit of a moot point like
they kind of told you how things are going to
play out she'll wind up uniting the world making
their marriage a moot point they won't have to
get married and she'll be able to do whatever
she wants to like she can go off with this Jade
character that she's actually in love with Braden
also tells her flat out that he he didn't want
to get married to her either so obviously he'll
be happy when they don't have to get married
eventually they explained the gaels the title
of the episode are a group of villains serving the
withered Crone like a group of her minions I think
the reason why they wind up kidnapping the prince
instead of going straight for olora Dannon is just
because of when the protection that the barrier
offered she was still hidden from their sight they
didn't know that it was actually heard they were
looking for and also it might be a ruse like the
withered Crone might actually be using the prince
against her to make her do something evil sort of
like an Emperor Palpatine Anakin Skywalker
situation where Palpatine psychologically
manipulated Anakin into eventually falling to
Darkness like the withered Crone is trying to do
the same thing eventually with the Laura Danon
when sorsha explains this other side prophecy
about bad morta's Spirit resurfacing inside her
descendants sorsha her children the whole idea
I think is that sorsha will wind up playing dual
roles in the series like something will corrupt
her and she'll play a villain during part of the
series because if you look at her IMDb it lists
sorsha is the role she's playing and then like
question mark somebody else like it's dot dot
dot you know to be revealed I think they're just
foreshadowing the bad morta spirit will take over
her at some point and she'll just play one of
the villain characters not the main villain but
one of the villains and the whole idea is the
withered Crone lives on this other continent
nearby across this shattered sea where nobody
theoretically has ever gone it's just another way
to show you that the world of the willow universe
is way way bigger most of the events of the movie
took place within a relatively localized area the
title of episode 2 is the high aldwin which is a
reference to Willow's character that's the role
that the sorcerer who led his village played in
the first movie like he's taken his place and
started to lead his people there's a bunch of
jokes during this episode that are all references
to jokes from the first movie like using the bones
the finger test not really knowing what's going to
happen like Willow here is waffling in this scene
like yes I know exactly what is going to happen
next maybe in a couple weeks she'll know what to
do that was part of the joke in the first movie
The Sorcerer didn't know what they were supposed
to do like I don't know if figure it out while
you're going they also flash back to Willow after
the events of the first movie visiting sorcia a
couple years later to talk about Laura Dan and
the prophecy wanting to train her worried that
the magic will fade within her that's also a bit
of a Star Wars metaphor too like the whole idea of
grogu for instance within the Star Wars Universe
his abilities faded over time he forgot some of
his Jedi training until Luke Skywalker helped him
remember it so it's kind of the same deal with
the Laura Dana like she's really bad trying to
practice magic they have a bunch of jokes about
that too like I can't figure this stuff out until
she eventually just does it without thinking about
it she's able to do all these things unconsciously
at the end of the episode she does grow the plant
they also have a joke about her wanting to use
Willows one like no no you can't use this as too
powerful it's this big conduit and magical energy
but it's kind of a Marvel Thor's hammer kind of
reference like the power is within a Laura Dana
like she has all the power she needs the one
is just a physical object you use to channel
the power there's no special magical power in the
actual wand itself the relationship between Willow
and Elora Danan is kind of like Obi-Wan Kenobi
and Anakin Skywalk Walker like the whole idea
that Obi-Wan Kenobi great Jedi but not nearly as
powerful as Anakin Skywalker is supposed to be and
still tries to train him as much as he can if he
didn't realize here too when they're meeting the
rest of their people the person playing Willow's
daughter in the series is actually Warwick Davis's
real life daughter she wasn't in the movie because
she hadn't been born yet when they made it I think
the reason why you don't see his wife is because
she's supposed to have died at some point after
the events of the movie when Brayden starts
talking to Elora Danan about studying Arcana
magic being good at that kind of stuff it
sounds like he either wants to Apprentice or
he has already started to practice magic himself
overall the episodes are pretty decent but it is
a very why a take on the fantasy genre like I said
it's sort of like George Lucas's vision of a Pure
Fantasy Star Wars type of story it also sort of
feels like them trying to do their version of
Game of Thrones or House of the Dragon but for
a much younger audience so depending on how you
like why a material like that your mileage will
vary on the series I don't know how many seasons
they have played I think it just depends on how
season one performs there'll be eight episodes
total the next big series after this will be
the Mandalorian Season 3 starting in February
Star Wars bad batch season 2 is also supposed to
start at the beginning of next year in Marvel's
what if season 2 will also start episodes around
that same time too I don't know if I'm gonna do
bad batch episodes but I will do Marvel what if
episodes in the Mandalorian season 3 episodes and
we'll see how this Willow video does how everyone
feels about the series if there's enough interest
I'll do more episode videos for it maybe a wrap
up finale video Marvel's doing a big Comic-Con
panel this week so we might have a new Ant-Man
in the wasp Quantumania trailer video maybe new
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer video maybe
some other trailers be sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss any of that everyone
click here for my new Deadpool 3 trailer to learn
about the big Crossover with Loki season 2 in my
new Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania Kang video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!